[Música]
es tan fácil renunciar a nuestros sueños
es tan fácil renunciar a soñar no volver
a soñar lo llaman lo que me tocó las
circunstancias y les voy a contar unas
historias personales tres historias
personales
en esa rebeldía contra las
circunstancias
la primera la llamo la pregunta creadora
cuando quedé embarazada de mi cuarto
hijo sorpresa el mayor estaba en el
bachillerato el segundo estaba en la
primaria el chiquito tenía un año y yo
trabajaba como una loca en serio
trabajaba muchísimo era claro que no
podía seguir siendo la misma persona
tenía que reconfigurar me por completo y
todo el embarazo y la licencia de
maternidad pensaba pensaba tenía dos
alternativas una era volver me amas de
casa y no solo por la plata sino porque
pues a mí me gusta mucho trabajar y no
me gustaba la elección y la otra era
como cambiarme de trabajo a un trabajo
que tuviera menor responsabilidad
tampoco me llamaba mucho la atención
porque tenía que delegar los niños a un
tercero y bueno en algún momento ya
desesperaba con tanta pregunta
el único recurso de lucidez fue abrir un
cuaderno y en la primera página escribir
en una hoja en blanco
quién debo ser a partir de este momento
y yo no sé cómo funciona eso sí es mi
mente si es el universo pero comenzaron
a aparecer oportunidades nuevas o al
menos yo comencé a ver que existían
otras oportunidades y se dieron las
cosas para que me convirtiera en una
empresaria comenzar a pensar como una
empresaria actuar con una empresaria y
con el apoyo de mi familia con sus
contribuciones nos conviene convertir
una empresaria hace ya ocho años de mi
empresa y mix
me siento súper orgullosa ha sido una
gran fuente de expansión un gran motor
de crecimiento para mí lo personal y
para mi familia siempre que me he
encontrado con una disyuntiva cuando hay
preguntas cuando hay alternativas que no
son satisfactorias una pregunta te
ilumina una pregunta te abre
posibilidades que te muestran nuevos
caminos que te pone en evidencia los
miedos
elegir una pregunta cuestionar tu
estructura de pensamiento es un gran hub
para tu vida
la segunda historia es una historia de
mente y espíritu
yo digo medio en broma medio en serio
que cada hijo que tengo se me lleva
muchas neuronas un paquete grandes son
brillantes y uno comienza a pensar
diferente a hacer está estudiado es
cierto las mamás dentro de la
neuroplasticidad del cerebro nos
volvemos tornillos muy mal sobre todo
menos arriesgadas nos volvemos
diferentes lentas yo no sé diferentes
en este proceso yo vivía pues cuatro
hijos imagínense la cantidad trabajando
un montón una multitarea yo hacía tres
cuatro cosas al tiempo un bebé
alimentando el otro aquí chateando con
un cliente hablando por teléfono
cogiendo tres cosas una experta en
multitarea y ese yo decía no puedes
hacer una sola cosa el tiempo pues qué
desperdicio imposible me cuestionaba a
mí misma me sentía muy orgullosa de mi
supuesta productividad
y bueno el costo de eso es que me estaba
enloqueciendo mi cabeza a millón a
millón a millón no me sentía a gusto y
empezó en ese momento una búsqueda la
búsqueda de tomar distancia de sus
pensamientos la búsqueda de la calma
fue y fui buscando por el mundo
respuestas y encontré mucho más porque
lleva buscando conocimiento en esos
viajes y a una conferencia porque quería
un conocimiento en la cabeza y encontré
muchas más cosas me encontré la
experiencia como un elemento de
transformación me descubrí viajar como
estrategia desanclar sé del status quo
descubra a mi esposo es el gran
compañero de aventuras y descubrí que
más allá de las cosas que uno sabe las
cosas que uno hace las prácticas son las
que hacen una gran diferencia
la meditación descubrí la meditación
como estrategia de tomar distancia de
los pensamientos descubrir la
respiración como estrategia volver al
presente descubrí la naturaleza y esa
conexión con la nata con la naturaleza
con una gran fuente de reconexión
practicarla
y practicar activamente
elegir estrategias que traigan calma a
tu vida es un gran jaque
la tercera historia es una historia de
mente y de cuerpo
ya les dije que tenía cuatro hijos y que
trabajaba mucho cualquiera coincide en
que no tengo tiempo para mí no tenía
tiempo para mí
en esa búsqueda comenzó a salir a la
búsqueda de la mente una maestra de
tantra de yoga me hizo recordar que la
caleña que tenía caderas que me gustaba
moverme y comencé a buscar en el cuerpo
en el cuerpo y comencé también no solo a
buscar en el movimiento sino en el
placer en ese momento en mi vida no
tenía claro ya o sea yo había
desaparecido entre tantos roles
yo no me acordaba que algo que me
gustaba se me ha perdido había dejado de
existir como persona por ser tantas
personas para ver temas para los demás
me encontré con el movimiento y comencé
a preguntar que me gustaba y fue así
como este perro llegó a nuestra vida
me dijo a alguien oye pero esos perros
tienen que correr misma media hora
diaria y joey no no es el único a mí se
me ha gustado correr y comenzamos a
correr primero el cachorro y yo con las
rodillas adoloridas le damos vueltas a
la cual al parqué
y muy rápidamente me comencé a ver que
eso es una delicia que era el perro
feliz el aire de la mañana era tiempo
para mí era un momento para mí solita y
como convencional gusto sí y muy
rápidamente me logré construir ese
hábito para mi existencia yo sacaba a
los niños de la ruta con el perro en la
calle a correr fantástico y me gustó
tanto que lo hice más más más y muy me
convertí en maratonista en los últimos
dos años
23 medias maratones dos maratones 42
kilómetros es un recorrido larguísimo es
un recorrido transformacional porque la
persona que inicia con ese sueño es una
y la que termina el recorrido es otra te
transforma no sólo el cuerpo te
transforma la mente
elegir apasionarte por aquello que te
hace feliz es un gran hub para tu vida
elegir hábitos que contribuyan con tu
bienestar es un gran hack para tu vida
y aquí vamos a hablar de herramientas
algunas herramientas que es cubierto
dentro de ese proceso la primera
herramienta es el autoconocimiento
desde platón conócete a ti mismo
pero la mayoría nos desconectamos de
nosotros nos perdemos si yo le pregunto
a mis amigas sobre todas las amigas qué
es lo que te hace feliz y muchas veces
me se quedan con la mirada en blanco y
me dicen quedan como respuestas pasivas
no puedes ver a mis hijos felices o
marathon arme una serie de netflix no sé
hay que perseguir aquí tenemos que estar
en contacto con nosotros mismos para
poder encontrar aquello que nos va a
permitir estructurar nuestra propia vida
y nuestro propio camino
la segunda herramienta ocúpate de tu
bienestar
es muy sabio el que dice que uno no da
lo que no tiene usted no puede dar paz
si no tiene paz que no puede dar fe en
sí no tiene fe usted no puede dar salud
si no tiene salud tu principal
responsabilidad es contigo mismo
cuidarte a ti mismo cuidar tu cuerpo
cuidar tu mente cuidar tus emociones
cuidar tus relaciones cuidar tus
finanzas cuidar tus entornos
preocúpate por ti y da desde tu propio
bienestar es nuestra responsabilidad
hemos hablado mucho de la manera de
pensar y cuando hablamos de elecciones
nuestra mente nuestro pensamiento
nuestro main set
generalmente son muchos muchos
pensamientos pensamientos de cosas de
las que no somos conscientes de cuando
el niño me dijeron el otro día escuché
que me pareció una cantidad de
pensamientos que no son conscientes
desarrollaron el hábito de cuestionar la
manera como pensamos nos permite
independencia nos permite contribuir en
esa dirección
es mejor ser un aprenderlo todo que un
sabelotodo cuando nosotros ponemos
nuestro autoconcepto en lo que sabemos y
no es lo que podemos aprender
nos volvemos vulnerables a la crítica
pero cuando nuestro autoconcepto está en
nuestra capacidad de aprender y de
seguir siendo unos eternos aprendices
ahí cuando sale algo mal no importa
porque podemos hacerlo mejor la próxima
vez
tus hábitos tus hábitos tus hábitos son
los que construyen el rumbo de tus años
cuando hablamos de cuando alguien me
dice es que yo no puedo dejar la
cocacola
yo no puedo dejar el cigarrillo o desde
que nacieron mis hijos yo me lo volví a
hacer esto que antes amaba
estamos siendo víctimas de nuestros
propios hábitos hay que liberarse es el
momento de liberarse todo se puede
aprender y una vez todo se aprende algo
se aprende todo se puede convertir en un
hábito y se puede convertir en hábito
con práctica haciéndolo cambiar ser
dueño a tus hábitos te da un nuevo rumbo
a tu vida te da años te da calidad
la última la última herramienta es
construir nuestra propia visión
cuando hablamos de nuestra visión a
veces nos
nos quedamos como en blanco no nacer
crecer reproducirnos morir o ser esta
persona o ser esta otra persona la
propia visión es tomar distancia de
nuestras circunstancias inspirarnos
soñar seguir soñando
cultivar nuestra mente para encaminarnos
en esa dirección esa es una gran gran
estrategia para cada vez ser más
autónomos y más libres
y bueno esto es una invitación una
invitación para soñar para seguir
soñando para revelarnos
para hacer cada vez más dueños de
nuestra propia vida y de nuestra
existencia
la elección es el hack
vale la pena intentarlo